[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
where we talk about whatever we want and
today we touch and fit me here good beer
yeah you're doing do that matching
tattoos on both feeders on a noise just
one no just one what does that say just
one can okay and well it looks like a
Asian character meant to be designed
like that but sideways ki yeah how does
your mom feel about your Asian
exploitation of the kynges world please
elaborate how does she feel about your
career choice is good now as long as I
pay the bills they don't matter what I
do I mean my mom would like you got to
be a doctor my mom had a difficult time
maybe understanding and seeing what was
not traditional right especially for
their generation you know being my first
generation Asian immigrant parents did
it live in a village they they pretty
much lived in villages out in Vietnam so
when they came over you know met in
Hawaii
and got married and then had my sister
yeah in the US and then came over had me
you know pretty much the world my whole
childhood they were running like a dry
cleaners you know and when you run a dry
cleaners that's like one stereotypically
Asian and then two it's it's a this is
honest work right you just work really
it's work just clean people's clothes
labor all day every day so your
understanding of like your own life and
what you're working hard for it to give
your children that opportunity the
classic story of just like you know I'm
gonna work my ass off and just stuff
that I'm cleaning other people's clothes
my whole life in order to let you have
an opportunity to go to college so buy
you a new clothes so I go to college
spend all this money right on a degree
and a bachelor's degree but you don't
you say well technically I make you know
youtube videos but you don't use that
trust me mm-hmm and then after you go
get a degree you're like [ __ ] this
degree I'm gonna go dance that's why you
backstabbed me [ __ ]
she said exactly so psychically speaking
you flip-flopping [ __ ] why don't you
stick with why you [ __ ] chose man
when you chose that major what did you
even get push girl what did you load
your matron I made you to film that's
not traditional no but it's fun where
they cool with that
that's like that's already like I think
so because I think you're already in
college you know what I'm saying if it's
like offered in a reputable place then
you you must accept it more you know
what I'm saying
I see but till I go back out and not
have a regular work force scheduled to
not have to clock in to stuff to not
receive a paycheck from other people
yeah you ever tell your mom that there's
like social media studies now in college
and that was actually blown away actual
like being the study now I mean it's
it's funny to like apply for a bunch of
schools and get rejected right when
you're like in high school and then like
you guys know a social media for
monsters we've like gone to those same I
believes now and like done presentations
I picked their [ __ ] that's true you
know so like just that conversation has
been able to like shift people's
perspective that is funny you got you're
going to speak and teach the students
that you got rejected
hello reject say some of them are Ivy
League's do not even apply it because I
knew I didn't have a chance
it would've been a waste of money so
funny what are you guys you guys I hear
your story do what the hell my story man
do your parents your dad ever go oh my
son he's stupid he's a fairy man he just
move around [ __ ]
yeah music that he just [ __ ] up it's a
weak little round and [ __ ] I don't think
so my dad had a little bit more openness
and logic to back up his understanding
yeah she was she is a pretty much like a
manager I think of financial like
brokers and stuff oh very you know
owns a home got married has two children
very very great example role model so
that that's easy for a parent to digest
oh yeah for example I definitely look
like a rebel cast like what about your
whole and your whole family to like out
of your cousin black sheep for show she
didn't learn piano don't speak Chinese
you know didn't make it into the good
schools don't
like a traditional kind of work
environment all that but love it we are
an entrepreneur
heyyo they seem like all the all your
Studios in like they have now and maybe
they go - that's high yeah that's been a
I feel like that's the most tangible
thing for like a Asian parent right it's
like yo I started this conceptual
company this group like can't just LLC
as a performance group like okay cool so
here's a dojo oh you have a place you
know any I understand it's like you have
a you build a million-dollar app and
they're like when you gonna get a real
job and then you're like working at the
post office and they're like that's
right that's not that's my son right
there
my dad just doesn't get anything unless
it's in the newspaper like a good actual
physical newspaper so I was telling him
about you know YouTube and maker studios
for years and he was just like I don't
know like you didn't go to school like
you didn't get a regular job whatever
and and it's not acting it's not like -
you know traditional media but then like
five years later he's like like VidCon
is going on and he read about maker
getting sold to Disney for you know half
a billion dollars and he was like have
you heard of maker studios I'm a dad
I've been yes like I was telling you
about this for like five years he's like
well they just got bought by Disney and
there's a video convention going on
right now and there's a have you heard
of angry cat and grumpy cat he's like I
don't know there's a famous cat it's
gonna be there the annoying camera is
you read about it in a newspaper oh wow
I was gonna be our version of that to
our kids right Twitter didn't have a
yeah we won't even know than you
actually know it's tick tock that's I
should know I'm literally in the example
like we're both the example cuz Isaac
will come up to me and he'll be like Oh
Mon let me do it and like he's trying to
do this one thing and I'm like what are
you doing he's like oh I learned this
from the tick tock and I'm like what
does he make tick tock content now - oh
no he I'm terrible
he doesn't he just consumes it okay
what's cool about my dad now is he so he
watches our vlogs and that's how he
stays caught up to our life which is
pretty cool cuz in quarantine doesn't
really come over that much and so now I
think because he's watched it so much
and he watches all the videos YouTube is
a thing to him now like he knows it's an
actual thing I think on earth he's
finally caught up so like the other day
forefathers and when he came over to
hang out what tyka he saw me grab the
camera and it goes Oh movie time because
now he knows oh that's my job and that's
my work he's like now he's respected
stay out of my son's wake he's about to
make a movie right you know back in the
day we were you doing the skits like we
would want him to be quiet
like we're about to roll and like we
have the [ __ ] mic that light set up
not just in small characters that an
actual camera you would give two [ __ ]
about it like I mean he's like I'm not
talking I'm he starts cooking yeah I
know isn't he making some soup ones or
something alright
she was what I'm watching TV he's like
Paul say anything anything you stuck to
my daddy got any noise music all right
cool I wasn't talking and it's like the
last soap opera I'm like dad you can't
you can't be watching TV there he goes
he goes in the kitchen oh my god in that
conversation of like I guess general
generally speaking like Asian parents I
kind of have that you know traditional
understanding do we feel like there's a
more like this ethnic Asian group has a
more traditional parent perspective
versus like bit like what would be the
ranking beef I think it's not so much
culture but okay when you think about
Asian immigrants right I was I was
questioning this for a long time because
I'm like why was my family different
from Bart's or 11 when Joe goes in this
mode by the way mode you can see women's
bodies shoulders are put back his chest
a little bit puff his feet are on the
ground instead of on
centered no accents and doesn't like the
topic that's like putting his hair in
ponies oh yeah I was gonna do that right
now too but I forgot my my band uh-huh
but anyways okay think about the
population that's here and when you hear
the that the most it's from war refugees
it's from people that didn't want to
leave Asia but they have to be here
because they were they needed a second
chance so they're all in survival mode
so when you're in survival mode right
everything else is like why are you
gonna do art why are you gonna do all
you're like this is [ __ ] stupid make
money so their mentality is if you spoke
to a like upper-class Asian family
that's old money they've been
generationally rich I highly doubt that
they disrespect the Arts like the poor
population does because they know that
there's famous painters there they know
there's classical musicians they know
all that or like now they have vesting
in the arts exactly and they understand
business they're like so if you're if
your kid is gonna become an entrepreneur
they're gonna build this or whatever
they're way more educated but what
you're talking to when you say quote
unquote Asian parents you're talking to
poor people who came here uneducated and
they don't understand the world as much
because their scope is like you said
from your parents they only know the the
drycleaner they that's all they know but
if you spoke to a Asian family that
maybe took time in college and they'd
they develop skills and in the arts and
then they they like that and if they're
a patron of the Arts that's a whole
different story
so I think that's why I'm like oh [ __ ]
so is it an Asian thing or is it a class
thing but it's like the majority I guess
of of most of the Asians that come here
they have when they share stories it's a
very similar story because I think most
people do come here looking for a better
life or looking for a second chance but
there's also like a lot of like rich
Asians that also I think are forced to
become doctors or lawyers or or whatever
yeah you gotta keep it on track
with the white-collar jobs or whatever
saying it there's that problem what do
you think about like Indians like Indian
culture because a lot of them aren't
like super poor but they still are very
the same kind of the same kind of route
of like be a doctor I think I that's why
I said generational money and a patron
of the Arts and the family don't have
this concept of you have to be like
that's not real wealth real wealth is
your trust fund you don't have to ever
worry about money again but they do care
about prestige so they might not be okay
with you being a DJ but maybe if you
become like a musician in the or another
way but an example is this a lot of
wealthy like Taiwanese ABCs right if
they're like not doing so hot in the
States or whatever but the kids want to
be a artist or a musician or a pop star
this is a common thing that I heard from
my Taiwanese friends is that they just
go to Taiwan and they become someone
famous or whatever so I'm like mmm is it
an Asian thing or is it more class thing
and new money to me is still not the
upper echelon so you're talking about
the 1% there's a 1% there that doesn't
care about needing to be a doctor or a
lawyer or just making means like from a
traditional passive income rather than
like you're working 80 hours as a doctor
to get six figures with even the
Taiwanese example so I knew a bunch of
those kids too and I have friends in
Taiwan that are also like on the pop
star level a lot of them when they come
here they're still trying to go into med
school and if they can't make in a med
school they go back so one of the most
famous ones is names leehom wang all of
his parent all of his brothers and
sisters are all doctors still so even
though they're their old money over
there I think just certain professions
holds such a high level of prestige that
when they come here they want to be the
American version of that because they
know how dope I guess being a doctor is
over there so imagine being an American
doctor and they come here and that
that's still what they pursue and I
can't do that then I guess I'll be the
Jason Derulo of Taiwan I mean maybe it
is different kinds of Asians then
because here's the thing like I don't
know if other Asian country
because I can only speak about Japan are
into classical music the way that they
are so like in Japan they'll have a lot
of shows and all that I'm pretty sure
they might in China as well but like
there's a lot of patronage --is to the
arts and there's a lot of craftsmen who
are highly revered directors film makers
and all that stuff so I don't maybe
you're right maybe it's like if you're
Vietnamese you're more like likely to be
pushed to go into the medical field
because its first generation wealth true
well speaking of for like China I feel
like the Mao era too had a lot to do
with how I think the current Chinese
population views I think you know wealth
and and jobs and job security right
because like I feel like the Mao era did
away with a lot of the arts and did away
with a lot of the philosophy and culture
and so I don't know if there is the same
steam as like yeah I look at it like
Japanese uh like like the way they live
and the way like that there's a lot of
respect and the craftsmanship and how
they do things how to restaurants
conduct themselves whereas China is like
almost the exact opposite so you're
right there is a difference there yeah
like it's not so much money practical
driven there is a soul to things that
you take pride in out there so then
that's why I'm like okay I I do here
that they want kids to be a certain
thing but they don't have such limited
choices compared to like my Vietnamese
friends my Vietnamese friends it was
always doctor lawyer engineer whereas
like Japanese was like you better kill
it and what you're doing but if they
don't understand like dads maybe that
might not be cool but they'll understand
like like maybe classical music and then
they'll be like okay my son's a great
pianist and you know he work he does
concerts but even in that sense I feel
like maybe because I've hyper analyzed
this right but like when you can't go
something like a being a classical
musician just historically does maybe
more of an random concept of an
understanding that like there's an
economic pathway in that life it's
prestigious
and exactly whereas like with something
that you maybe don't understand is much
like an industry like dance in America
you know what I'm saying it's like how
are you gonna make money is the
superseding thought versus do you love
it well yet so that's what I mean by
survival right so the goal in these
Asian parents it's always survival how
are you gonna make money whereas like
when Europe a privileged group you don't
think how are you gonna make money for
sure which I didn't hear that all the
time from my Japanese friends and their
families and all that stuff too whereas
like they want the procedure they want
the kids to kill it in something but
it's like let's say if a kid is like oh
I'm gonna be a philosopher because you
better go to [ __ ] Harvard then or
like you know you better do it well so
then maybe the the the expectation is
still there but then the limited choices
are removed because I had a friend she
wanted she's Vietnamese and she wanted
to be a oceanographer and her parents
was like [ __ ] no why are you gonna do
that she got into a really good school
but she's like you're gonna be a
pharmacist and I heard that that was a
really common thing where if a parent
doesn't understand outside of what
exists in the medical field in some
Asian groups it's just the medical field
that's the only thing you're allowed to
do and I'm like damn that's crazy and I
guess that's why I came up with the with
the thought of oh they're in survival
mode because they're only thinking about
a high-paid job cuz their parents are
like I don't want you to struggle like
me well I mean you grew I didn't have
like the hardcore parents where you
can't like do anything can't explore
like they want they put me into art
classes they put me into all sorts of
like music classes and sports and stuff
like that and they just so relate to the
ages that have those stories me and my
parents and aunt Ida probably way more
similar do you still relate when you
hear that I relate because I had a
friend and who was actually white who
had a really strict parent and he was
like hardcore a hardcore Christian
family and was very like kind of
old-fashioned in a sense that there's a
really only one way to the top and it's
like through honesty honest work and
things like that and nothing nothing too
frivolous you know like you didn't
really have a whole lot of frivolous
things and and
his like you know view of life did he
have to be a doctor too
yeah yeah but you know something in the
medical industry yeah and I think his
brother was on his way to go into
medical school whenever my friend was
like you know what I can't deal with
such pressure his dad was pretty like my
my dad would always be like because I
would complain to my dad like my dad
like you like you gotta ease up on like
your the way you talk to people it's
like you're very off-putting you're very
strong and he was like what about what
about Adams dad and then you know and
he's like and I'm like fine you guys
you're right I don't have it that bad
but yeah like so I learned a lot of that
kind of [ __ ] from a non-asian family but
then once I do talk to you guys and I'm
like I can relate because I just I am
aware you know but I didn't I definitely
didn't have that granted I don't think
it's like a lack of understanding
knowledge or like appreciation for like
the or subculture but like in survival
mode when you can't afford you know what
it means and things like that it's like
not even a conversation topic like it's
if I I remember wanting to do like NJB
as a kid at the Boys and Girls Club down
the street it was what does that JP
stand for some basketball junior
basketball I'm thinking you're
basketball anyways um yeah and I just
wanted to play basketball you know your
kid and all all the boys in your class
are a part of the NJB after-school
program you know but it just costs money
just cost X amount of money so it was
never even allowed prison you did talk
about law right I did because I wanted
to do kung fu with my cousin but kung fu
cost more so everything was an economic
decision down the street was very
cheaper that's why their decisions for
you is how you're gonna make money
because they're faced with survival
every day and it makes sense that both
their parents are this way cuz you said
they had a hard life at a laundromat in
your dad [ __ ] swam running away from
China and he was in poverty so it makes
sense right that's kind of my theory and
I think it's it's pretty right because
the parents that grew up with privilege
and let's say they're middle class they
went to college like your parents were a
little bit more privileged so they have
this freedom to go yeah you guys could
do whatever you want my parents are
actually what's the proper word crazy
you can't say this word I'm started are
cuz they're actually switched they're
ridiculous so my parents were switched
because I say that word ridiculous yeah
righteous okay because my mom is college
educated and she comes from my grandpa
who was also college educated so there's
like they're not on survival mode but
she had this survival like type of
mindset that I had to become a doctor my
dad was a refugee who had to eat his own
and he didn't even go to Lanka his own
captain cat food no cat that's how poor
they were and and my dad was the one
when he was like I don't care what you
do after you go to college but we're in
America and so I want you to go to
American school and then the American
thing to do is make your own choices
after you go to school and pick what you
want to do so it was just kind of like
it was it was like switch like the main
pressure was from my mom to have to
become a doctor my dad did want me to go
to graduate school of some sort I think
that's what he understood of how you
really secure your success so he didn't
care if it was like lawyer or whatever
but that's where he understood but at
least there was more choices from my dad
than my mom do you think I lost
education system creates a crippling
effect in someone's mind where like
you're so used to being told what to do
from grade to grade to grade to get to
college and there's like so much
structure and built into the education
system by the time you get out you're
just looking for that same structure is
for something to tell you what to do
what's my schedule like wonder why
should I go to sleep what should I eat
what job should I get right whereas like
some that didn't really go follow the
education education system isn't college
educated might be a little more like
self inspired to just kind of like I
make my own rules you know and yeah
could be yeah I take it back I don't
know about background anymore I just
think one is stubborn and one is more
flexible so it's not Asian thinking it's
just a lot of stubborn [ __ ] that
don't want to be flexible
[Laughter]
[Music]